foreign
do you remember well it was probably two
years ago now that people were starting
to talk about the bubble the bubble the
housing bubble is gonna it's gonna it's
gonna burst it's gonna burst it's gonna
be another 07 you know like the oh yeah
the freak out and then we did the big
the the reality the real estate
live stream and so you know the market
we've said it saw I mean it's cooled
down it's not as insane as it was but
then uh yep so we're stabilizing and so
uh on Instagram I know you love
Instagram reels uh a guy a guy I had a
whole thing about how the number one
market that's gonna burst very soon is
Nashville and how Nashville it's gonna
all this stuff and then I went and read
through the comments and they were like
are you insane like have you been to
Nashville and seen the econ because it's
it's still crazy in Nashville right I
mean like there's still there are still
fewer houses more guys still saying that
yes there's a guy that and I just saw it
the other week and I was like oh no not
Nashville because we we experience it
here and it's like people are still
flocking and still moving here uh but
what but I can't get you to not come I
know so for you and your perspective
with real estate specifically like what
what trends are you seeing
out there because I mean I kind of just
I I see Nashville and know Nashville but
overall the landscape the the bubble has
not burst
we are still okay but it has it has
softened right some I mean it's not as
it's not as urgent and freaked out as it
was but overall what are you what are
you saying I think um
you know I think we can just stop and
say I told you so can't we I mean
because we did like 18 months ago when
everybody was frantic because the market
had slowed down and interest rates were
coming up
we did a two hour long
live stream I would imagine you could
still watch it and go back and watch it
and I think you'll see in that that we
predicted exactly what has happened
now now we don't always get it right but
we were using data not emotions to
actually figure out what's going on and
the data was this there even though the
interest rates have gone up there still
is a dramatic inventory shortage in real
estate in almost every city
in order for prices of anything to come
down
Supply demand curves have to shift
meaning that the supply has to be much
higher than the demand
but when there is the opposite a
shortage
versus a glut in the market when there's
a shortage prices go up
so if you want to cause the prices on
something to go up make it scarce
make it make it be a shortage there is
not a shortage of real estate there is a
I mean there is a shortage of real
estate and so the the opposite of prices
tanking everybody's oh it's all going to
go away it's all going to be another
front two thousand and we kept saying no
it's not it's not going to bust it's not
going to bust it we said it is going to
slow down and we said if you're going to
sell a house you're going to have to
actually clean it up
and Stage it which is you know and you
can expect to put it on the market again
you can put it on the market you expect
90 to 120 days and you can expect not to
get 110 of your asking price with 87
offers on one weekend that was an
anomaly that was a short period of time
after covid when everybody sat around in
their house got fat and decided they
wanted to move out of their house
Lumber went up 3x it's back down uh and
Builders are Builders are not building
specs right now yeah they slowed down
and they're adding to this shortage
because the the it slowed down and they
don't they don't get stuck with a spec
house and so spec house starts our way
off which is hurting the inventory even
more you can't find a house in a lot of
markets so you have not seen prices
crash you've seen them steadily increase
we said in the year 2023 you were going
to see a two to a seven percent increase
in prices Nationwide and that is about
what we're going to see and that's what
your home is actually valued not the
inflated price that people are throwing
out there yeah right these people could
put an extra half a million dollars
something insane on you know and people
would just buy it this is not asking
price this is actual value that's right
that's right actual value and it's not
people buying like they've lost their
dadgum mines this is people reasonable
people buying properties at reasonable
prices you're going to see that number
you know you put a house on the market
for three hundred thousand dollars
expect to get a an offer you know of 280
and that you're going to negotiate yeah
and expect to sit there for 90 to 120
days to sell the house and expect that
if your house is ugly and dirty it's not
going to sell
so that's not unusual that's like 90 of
the years that we've had real estate
operating in America it's been that way
we had a short period of time when it
was cray-cray and we covered all of that
in detail and then it has happened
exactly the way we said yeah so no
whatever
characters on whatever Instagram
economists that's like it was funny
though it's like an oxymoron I'll be
honest I fall for everything I see on
the internet even though
that sometimes is the case
not everything I had a moment where I
was like oh gosh what does he see that
I'm not see I don't know and then you
know I'm watching it again I'm like that
just doesn't feel right and the funniest
part is just going to the comments
because people just ripping around
everyone's like I'm a real estate agent
National are you kidding me like smoking
something yeah so anyways it was it was
good but that's what you're saying
that's just good to know I think that
it's good to kind of just get a pulse on
um and then interest rates obviously are
they're up they're up and do you ever
see them coming back down to that to
three percent I don't know I I don't
know what interest rates are going to do
I will tell you this you can have a
healthy sustained realist residential
real estate market for home buyers and
six percent will just rock it for days I
mean we've rocked it for decades at six
percent the only reason it was driven
down below six yeah was artificially by
the government driving it down to
re-stimulate the real estate market
after 2008. but prior to 2008 for what
15 years it sat around six yeah you know
when I came on the air in uh
1992 doing this show the rates were like
nine
and we were selling lots of people
selling houses everywhere nobody thought
anything about it yeah and then they
came down to six and we thought oh this
is awesome this is great because six is
great when you're comparing it to nine
six is not great when you're comparing
it to two and a half yep yep you know
and so it's all your point of reference
the secret to happiness is low
expectations right so
oh my gosh but yeah that the you're
you're right we should have stopped and
said I told you so because we don't know
what I was asking no I I you will take
this moment no we really should do that
every so often because we get so much
stupid hate mail by people on these uh
social media channels and everything
else that we don't know what we're
talking about and we completely nailed
that yeah I mean our team here and I the
Ramsey personalities looked at the data
and we said this is what's going to
happen and we hammered it we nailed it
and it certainly wasn't the crash of the
real estate market that a lot of you
or believing
and predicting was going to occur 18
months ago
just think back to 18 months ago and
that's about when we did that live
stream so go look it up